[Musique]
nous allons ce soir si vous le voulez
bien
oubliez un instant la fébrilité tout
apparente de notre vie quotidienne pour
visiter ensemble 5e arrondissement
c'est le quartier de la jeunesse et le
quartier des étudiants de la sorbonne au
collège de france combien d'étudiants
étrangers n'oublieront jamais c'est nous
en passant par polytechnique ou tout
simplement le lycée henri iv
des hommes des générations d'hommes ont
glané la tous leurs souvenirs de
jeunesse
saft il que cette à philippe auguste
qu'ils le doivent puisque c'est en l'an
12 sans que le roi de france octroyer à
ses lettres de noblesse universitaire à
ce quartier dit latin
carrefour des manifestations des chahuts
d'étudiants la place saint michel et son
archange de bronze qui regardent de ses
yeux vides de le quai où coule la seine
c'est qu'est frangé de bouquinistes ou
ce but la plus petite rue de paris
immortalisée par honoré de balzac la rue
du chat qui pêche
non loin de là havre de verdure le
square saint julien le pauvre ascquois
un peu triste de par son nom mais qui
verdoie entre les clochers ceux de notre
dame au loin et tout proche celui de
saint julien le pauvre
si vous prenez la rue saint-jacques et
la première route nationale de france et
si vous tournez tout de suite à droite
vous découvrirez les merveilleuses voûte
de saint séverin
sa belle architecture gothique cerner
entre les maisons
elle vous livrera tout de même la beauté
de ces pierres
c'est aussi l'un des plus vieux
quartiers de paris c'est ici qu'en jean
ben lahcen lutèce s'agrandit et que les
romains occupant la gaule bâtir des
arènes des palais et des thermes à cluny
dont subsistent encore quelques vestiges
que l'on visite sonorisé par les
voitures qui passent sur le boulevard
saint germain
c'est le quartier le plus paradoxal de
paris c'est le plus jeune et le plus
vieux de notre capitale
il vous a par moments des petits airs du
moyen-âge qui vous ravissent et vous
inquiète tout à la fois
les noms des rues même où des
consonances suranné les enfants ils
jouent sans rien voir et certaines
maisons n'y voit que d'une fenêtre en
déambulant dans ses rues étroites vous
serez surpris par ces cours sordide où
toute tentative de nettoyage se heurte à
la poussière et à la patine des siècles
paradoxal nous vous l'avions dit dans
une même rue vous pourrez selon que vous
regardiez à gauche ou à droite
changer de siècle et de vie
vous ferez peut-être halte de ce café où
se réunir pour conspirer les sergents de
la rochelle reprenant votre marche vous
irez d'un seul élan ce n'est pas très
loin jusqu'aux pieds de saint-etienne du
mot sur la montagne sainte geneviève
jeunes vieux paradoxal ce 5ème
arrondissement c'est aussi le quartier
le plus libre de paris on y vit comme on
veut aussi habits comme on le désire ou
comme on peut
et le meilleur exemple vous en sera
donnée si vous le souhaitez place de la
contrescarpe ce sont les derniers
clochard de paris leur vie se déroule
mollement sur cet îlot de macadam sans
aucune gêne de leur part ni attention
particulière des riverains
les riverains qui pendant ce temps sa
ferme usta dans ce boyau rétréci par les
voitures de quatre saisons où viennent
déchoir toutes les senteurs des jardins
de france et d'ailleurs
le 5ème arrondissement voyez vous c'est
tout cela c'est une ville c'est un monde
et c'est aussi un peu d'histoire de
paris
[Musique]